dea
興味深い人物に溢れる非常に長い歴史世界中の人々に愛されている独特な食文化
大人でも楽しめるユニークなアニメ基本的に僕は日本が大好きだ
しかしどうしても気に入らないところが一つだけ予想
僕は日本のスーパーが嫌いだスーパーに行かなければならないと思うとゾッとする
スーパー
癒しを踏み入れた瞬間に悪夢が始まる大きな波のように10代のオタクがテンションを
上げるために効きそうな音楽が体を包むのたは流数
照明が眩しすぎて目が痛い秋葉原のゲームシセン隆也と思わずつぶやくそして
バスケットへと手を伸ばすしかしそこでも絶望が僕を待ち構えている
バスケットの小ささ
と言ったらない[ __ ]がピック肉に行くときに持っていきそうのパスケットちっちゃいと
いう言葉の語源がこのバスケットにあったに違いない作った人の脳みそを検査したく
ない僕はなのバスケットを手にして果物売り場に向かうこう毎週大体の地物を食べる
するでスーパーに行くとだいたい同じものを買うそれならスーパーにいる時間がとても
短いはずだ
歯科
し現実は違う短いどころかスーパーに入ると時間がにじむ100が100人もいるのに
レジ店員が1人しかいなかったり足を1m ほどを進めるのに何カ月もかかるおばあ
さんたちに囲まれたりそれから見て外人だと体を凍りつかせる子どもたちに阻まれたり
神様は意地悪をして買い物がなかなか進ま
興味深そうにミカンを見比べるおばあさんとひどく太っている者を学生に挟まったまま
僕は花のバスケットに入れる
または流数魚に近づくとゼウスから曲球を喰らう
もう一つ全然違う曲が流れているかもサバの山の上に置いてあるラジカセから
作詞家はきっとヴィーガンだったんだ複雑に交錯している二つの層を聞いていると魚を
釣っている電車男が浮かび上がり気が遠くなる
定員が正気を保っているのは奇跡に等しい久しぶりにピーナッツバターを買おうか派と
思ったらバカだったピーナツバターなんてものはもちろんいい夏バターと書いてある
食後のプリティ
ほぼ同じ大きさの容器があってその中に生きているように見える液体は入っている
けれど
ピーナツバターは何もかかわらず絶対にバスケットに入らないくらい大きなマヨネーズ
館ずらっと置いてあるレジに向かうと同時に恐ろしい事実に気づくレジのあたりでもう
一つ全く違う曲が流れている田舎よ排泄なことを
オールいうような右を円状のスピーカーの質が埋まり2号歩くとして音量があまりにも
大きくこれから顔果物思わず店員に投げつけたくなる目から血が出ていないかと指で
隠れにする
まだ大丈夫みたいなさいませーポイントカードお持ちでしょうか
ないですかしこまりました後かオフィスた店員が歌うようにいう証明がまぶしすぎてね
いた子どもがをあなたは流星な魚作用ファッショ入りますか
えっあっいや
真っ黒いいますかポイントカードをお作りしましたからないですか
みんなリースでスッキリもとかよりっね橋は今から風
パダ
僕はスーパーから飛び出て秋のすがすがしい空気が入っぱいす行こう
鼓動が徐々に音程してくる大丈夫だまで生きてい
アパートに帰って偽物のピーナッツバターを食べよう
me
ええええええ